una carrera desesperada para huir del
país en estas imágenes diplomáticos
saudíes funcionarios y otras personas
abandonan su dan en barco hacia edad
el sábado Estados Unidos anunció el
cierre temporal de la embajada en jartum
y lanzó una operación militar para sacar
a su personal y a su familia Aunque el
secretario de estado Anthony blinken Se
comprometió a ayudar a los civiles
estadounidenses en el país Washington
afirma que por el momento no se está
planeando ninguna evacuación masiva el
domingo se supo que Francia había
comenzado a sacar a sus ciudadanos y
personal diplomático Mientras tanto los
civiles ciudadanos están organizando sus
propios intentos de huir del país sin
garantías de éxito
los pasajes de autobús son muy caros
vengo de abril por la mañana temprano y
el precio del pasaje es de unos 10 euros
pero cuando quiero volver a abrir el
precio de pasajes se convierte en 40
euros
el alto el fuego de tres días acordado
por la celebraciones de Elite se rompió
rápidamente durante el fin de semana Los
combates entre el ejército regular su
danés dirigido por el general abdel
fatal y las milicias de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido del país dirigidas por su
ex junto a moha han dejado ya más de 400
muertos y miles de heridos por ahora las
dos facciones rivales han descartado
cualquier solución negociada